agent Cooper such an iconic television
role and he's remembered watching that
when Twin Peaks first came out just
being blown away by the show and just
looking up to agent Cooper and really
being fascinated by his love of cherry
pie and coffee yeah and you have
admitted since you yourself do not love
cherry pop what's not my favorite right
and anything I'll lead eating dessert
that's fine but but no yeah cherry pie
apple pie that's my dad actually was the
cook in the family and he would make
terrific apple pies right that was my
favorite but what sherry was in there
but what's true to your character is
that you love coffee I do love coffee
and I still love coffee right and a
drink it black black is midnight on a
moonless night you could just say black
I just love you going into a diner
I'll have it is dark is there's only one
kind of black but you know I love is
that fans know this about you so fans
send you coffee related messages yes and
you got one they sent you f one fan sent
you a video and this video yeah and he
said this yeah you decided to share it
with us let's take a look at this this
is a fan video sent to comma clapping in
honor of his love of coffee
[Music]
[Applause]
you